the jay-z
and nipsey song that came out oh man so
you're you have co-production credit on
that song yes
so how did that happen i was in the
studio um like i'm always in the studio
working with uh
rants mars 1500 or nothing and ranch was
like yo we got this record like you know
what you want to do i want you to do
some [ __ ] on it i'm like what you want
me to do
like just do your dj head [ __ ] whatever
that means
so i was like all right so he plays me
the song and he's playing me the nipsy
vocals
over the beat right i'm like oh it's nip
record like
[ __ ] yeah let's do it i didn't know
nothing about hole
right at that time they were like we're
doing something really special with the
record they just couldn't tell me right
so he's like look just just do some cuts
on the song you know
do do some ins and outs some little
scratches whatever i'm like all right
bet
so i did i actually uh recorded it and
and then i turned it in and i ain't i i
didn't think none of it i was like oh
they must not have used it
i didn't know that it was a bigger play
like later on you know what i'm saying
obviously that's how the music business
work so when they were when it came time
to release the record
it was like oh this is the record and
then once it came obviously i had it
early and [ __ ] like right right um but
we couldn't talk about it because it was
like
a part of a rollout i'm like damn this
is crazy but i didn't know that they
were going to actually give me
credit on this like you know how like
you're producing right right right but
you might not get
you might not get visual credit on the
out on this on the record
so that was like a big deal for me that
was a huge
deal for me especially seeing like
jay-z's name nipsey's name
c and then i'm like right there that
[ __ ] was crazy
so when this song came comes out right
oh [ __ ]
so
you know when we were doing the night
show together yes
uh we really didn't care
to have songs first
no that's not my game it's just really
like no one cares
yeah like everybody gets the record at 9
pm like it's it's uh
not 2009 sure or even 2013 or
it's like yo fam like now
like you said you had the record for a
long time you know i mean
you got yeah you was in the studio right
this is before the whole vocals
so the la leakers
shout out to justin shout out to sour
milk um
sour milk well we were you someone when
we were doing the show together are you
talking about recently
recently okay this is after you and i
were not on the air this is
this is uh this is a recently recently
when this song came out right
what was this december january when did
i remember i think i said i have a bad
memory
so the leakers get the song
and they're going crazy before nine
o'clock obviously right
which has happened a lot yeah cool
sour milk goes on twitter
and says essentially
does anybody want to tell them that we
have we've been going crazy on this
however
long i don't remember the specifics of
the two well i tweeted i tweeted first
and i said
i'm i'm i'm probably i'm playing this at
nine o'clock
right and then he retweeted this yeah it
was just yeah you said yo we're going
crazy at nine yeah
i'm just promoting my show right you're
promoting your show which is what you
should do right you weren't saying
anything about anybody
i don't ever do that right he retweets
it
and pretty much says does anyone want to
tell i
i don't remember but we've been going
crazy on this the last two hours bob
i i know that it got interesting
uh because
i don't remember at what point in time
you replied with the credentials of the
song
that they were playing you know some
back and forth that you have publishing
on
that you produced and you thank them for
playing it for you because you have
production credit on the song now
from a strict perspective of someone
who's just
on twitter and i [ __ ] with
those guys you know they're cool like i
got no problems with them dudes like
you know uh me and justin are cool you
know i just saw justin uh
around the grammys and we you know we're
cool but i'll be
damned
if i have never seen anyone take a worst
l on from a radio perspective
on social media than that that was
rough
and then everyone just like
it went crazy yeah i didn't expect i
didn't know
and then letty chimed in she you know
obviously she's married to nipsey's uh
manager shout out to jorge uh george uh
and and and put her two cents in on it
about hey
it just it got out of hand
and and i don't mean like out of hand
like you didn't
you just literally was awesome like hey
thanks for supporting
by the way uh you might want to check
the credentials on that record
you had it so what happened with that
um that's that's exactly how we had some
back and forth
um and then he's he said something it
got kind of like it started to get
to me it started to get aggressive on
his behalf yeah
not on your behalf yeah so i was just
like it's not in your nature no
i'm i can't play like that this [ __ ] is
like again people take this radio [ __ ]
so serious it's like
fam this is for anyone not not for
anyone in particular
you work for a company that owns a brand
that you don't own listen man
calm down i just what i did was i just i
got swung on and i swung back
you swung back all right you swung back
then you pulled up
at their mama's house and monte carlo
you rolled the window down and put a uzi
out lit that whole [ __ ] up that's just
what i'm i was taught
that you don't start it you finish it
that's what my grandma always said
that's my family that's how we get out
so
i don't ever start anything i don't talk
tough i don't aggressive i don't even
sub people
i just promote my show yes so the
subliminal thing and that's my thing is
like
i've been a part of radio beefs in the
past uh
but i just kind of started to realize
like
hey it's stupid as [ __ ] because we're
gonna have to see each other
and the way i carry myself is
you you go see me i'm gonna reply to you
on social media because i ain't a social
you know i'm we're gonna run into each
other and then we're gonna have to have
this conversation face to face
and that's happened a few times where
i've had to
run up in vegas shout out to john moog
from kouc
who thought he could talk out the side
of his [ __ ] face and i wouldn't go
[ __ ] walk up to his ass right at the
low rider show and be like what's up
[ __ ] what you trying to do this
nigga's crazy you know what i'm saying
but what i'm saying but what i'm saying
is is like
you know you and i never like that's
just not what we do
no i don't play i don't play the bank
the radio bang game just because
i'm not allowed the luxury to fake beef
with people and that's something i had i
had a conversation with my superiors
before like i can't
fake beef with people because my lineage
and my my
my environment and my people don't allow
me that luxury to to like
oh let's be for less you know like it's
just my [ __ ] different and that's why i
had to tell them like i'm not
i always tell people like i'm not a
radio naked like i'm a [ __ ] who do
radio
so it's my [ __ ] different i can't play
like that
so that's why everything i do is a very
articulate approach
i'm never aggressive it's like hey so
when i when i did that it's like
i got swung on and i swung back that's
it
so what what i know that you went you
and milk talked after that
yeah we yeah um og got us on the phone
well
one one of my og shot the fuzz he hit me
he was like you know i need you to you
know talk to him
you know like i don't like this [ __ ]
right and so
um i told fuzz fuzzy's like i'll do
anything for fuzzy right
and i told him now so fuzzy i'll do
anything for you so put him on the phone
so we got on the phone we talked for
like half an hour or something like that
and i don't want to you know just get
all the details that come yeah but
everything's cool as far as i'm
concerned i let it go right
now that was after i did go on the air
with it
to be honest oh you should have yeah but
i'm a firm believer in utilizing your
platform
so i'm afraid i go i went on the air
with it the next day and
turned the music off and went in for
about two minutes as you should have
though very
very articulate i didn't call anybody
name i dressed people by name
but i didn't i remember hearing it i
didn't say anything disrespectful i just
addressed the issue
owned up to my to my antics as well and
then kept it pushing
it kind of felt like uh the moment
wasn't as
much about nipsey as it was about so who
the [ __ ] has got the song first
yeah i just felt like the moment got
taken away from what it was about and
everyone who knows
knows that nip always wanted to work
with hove of course so i felt like that
was the moment
and that moment was robbed when it got
made about radio politics
so that i didn't i didn't like that